You know,
when,
when you look back on your career,
like do you have like a most satisfying victory?
Yeah.
What is it?
Acim rock night was going to say that I was going to say the rematch,
the first or the second.
The second one.
The love of Christ.
When a guy,
when a guy beats you like that and then,
you know,
you could have beaten them or you should have beaten him.
Is that what bothered you so much?
Um,
no.
You know what really bothered me is the fact that I gave him an opportunity.
I gave him a fight when,
uh,
I'm basically waiting for Tyson and I have to keep busy.
I'm looking down the list of who to fight.
He's number seven.
I realized that he's durable.
He's not one of these guys that get knocks out easy.
So I wanted to give my fans,
you know,
a proper fight box,
the best guy out there and not bucks an easy guy that's easy to get knocked out.
I don't want to go home and two rounds.
So,
and then another reason a lot of people don't know.
I went to Africa to fight because Muhammad Ali went to Africa.
You fought in Africa.
So I wanted to do that.
I want it to be,
I wanted to fight in Africa.
You know,
I say I'm a world champion so I need to fight all around the world.
So that's what made me go to Africa.
The only thing about Africa is I didn't know that it was such a high altitude up
there.
And for me to have a fight,
I should have got there a lot earlier,
but I was doing ocean's 11 at that time.
He said,
Oh,
you would do in the movie.
I wasn't doing no movie.
I was sitting around half the time waiting for them to change the lights,
then go out and go up there for two minutes and then go back and sit there for
another two hours while they changed the lights.
So we training at all when that was happening.
Yeah,
always training.
But it wasn't like it wasn't the conditions of training.
You know,
I needed a bag,
I needed sparring partners.
That would be up there a lot sooner.
So you're just kind of acclimatize.
Yes.
How many thousand feet?
Was It above sea level?
Higher than a big beer?
There was Cape Town,
right,
so more than six.
Wow.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
it was kind of weird because when I started working I was like throwing punches.
Then I found myself going,
so I had to take two steps back and I'm like,
oh no,
no,
don't tell him this flight's going to be one of those fights where I have to
take my time.
So I basically went out there taking my time.
I realize he's dealing with the same thing I'm dealing with,
although he was there a lot earlier,
but you know,
I had a couple of things going wrong boxing up four in the morning.
Uh,
they couldn't find a big enough ring.
Then they,
when they put the room together,
it was like a 18 by 19 so,
and then the,
the punch that actually hit me,
I actually thought I was going to block it,
but it came around this side.
I'll put my hand,
I put my hand up to block it,
but it came round,
hit me one of those things where a man through a terrific punch with my chin
happened to be in the way of,
what is it like when that's over and you're sitting there and you know you lost,
but you know that under the right circumstances this guy is not at your level.
Uh,
in fact,
you know,
my problem was solved before I got out of the ring.
I knew what I did wrong,
which was the greatest thing that ever happened to me.
He's like,
Oh,
another day he,
he wouldn't throw lucky punch like that and it wouldn't hit me and he wouldn't
have a riff that,
you know,
was on his side as well.
How was the ref on the side?
Um,
when I say the refs on his side,
you know,
I got a little early,
I got knocked down in the second round.
I'm the,
I'm the champion,
at least give me a chance,
not waive the fight strip.
You know,
you've seen,
you've seen the Deontae a title.
Like,
you know,
if that was the ref,
he counted them out straight away.
That's what stopped it at the press conference 12th round.
That right left and Deontae landed the fact that Tyson got up and then one the
remainder of the round.
That is crazy.
Yeah,
I am so frustrated with that.
Fights not happening again,
man.
Every,
you know,
I'm looking at the heavyweight scene and um,
I'm looking at,
obviously I'm Joshua Joshua from England and you know,
he had the opportunity to fight Deontae and didn't take it.
I'm like,
if that was me,
I would've took that chance because you never know what happens down the road.
Likes what's happening now.
And uh,
you know,
to me he's being put on the shelf now.
He asked the puck somebody that nobody really wants him to balk cause he
fighting next a baby,
a baby,
middle of a big baby,
big baby milk,
you know,
big baby Miller.
I haven't seen too much of him.
I don't know too much about him,
but you know,
he talks a good fight.
I knew,
I know he weighed,
weighed over 300 pounds at one time.
And,
and yeah.
And uh,
you know,
now he's got an opportunity to fight to Joshua.
So he's taken full advantage of it.
Like he should.
But you know,
I don't see anything in his history to show me that he can beat Joshua,
you know,
move,
you peak and he can,
he can bang though.
He can bang.
If you're there to Bang Josh.
Joshua got feed,
he's going to move.
He's not going to stay there and bang,
it's an excellent boxer.
Yeah.
He's going to be a small box here in this fight,
allegedly.
We'll see.
Right.
I mean,
never know.
Yeah.
I mean this,
this isn't one of those things where I think this is where Anthony has gotta be
extra careful because is going to train twice as hard.
And if Joshua doesn't train,
like he's fighting Deontae he's gonna.
He may take it for granted,
make a mistake
and you can do that.
I've done that.
And it's nothing.
It's nothing that he's done on purpose.
It's not,
it's like it's a mental thing.
Yeah.
It's a mental thing.
Like when you find Maravich yeah,
that guy wouldn't go home.
Wouldn't go home.
Gave me a lot of trouble.
It was at that fight gave me a lot of trouble.
Um,
Lennox box,
this guy around the ring for 12 rounds,
like literally the guys heads snapping back in.
This guy's not going,
not going to be well,
he was going nowhere.
That is,
that's gotta be a weird feeling to when you know how hard you punch and you see
a guy just
eating them.
Like some people just are built weird.
They just can take a shot.
No,
I learned that coming up.
I learned that like,
Yo,
some guys that are tough to the head or week to the body,
uh,
some guys are tough to the body week to the head and some guys just made out of
rocks.
Yeah.
It's almost like a ignorant bliss.
They just don't know they're supposed to feel bad,
you know?
I don't know.
I mean,
I really think it's a physiological thing.
I think some guys can just take a shot.
They just,
they're just built better sometimes of being in fights.
Where have gone in.
The man's hit me on the Chin first couple minutes and it's likely just glanced
off my chin.
I was like,
I ate it.
I ate the Puncho and it didn't hurt me.
And it was like,
what happens?
I punch.
It was so hard.
It hit you on the chin.
Everybody was saying,
Yo,
did you see that punch?
He never felt it.
I'm like,
no.
And when I look at tape of it,
it's like,
wow,
I did get it.
Hm.
Is it because like,
are there a bunch of factors?
Like how much you got hidden training?
How well you feel coming into the fight?
Yeah.
There's where you're at in your career and there's a lot of factors.
Like for instance,
let me give you a good weekend factor.
If you have inbox for two years and all of a sudden you step into the ring and
it's a title fight and you box,
you got the first good hit you get is going to concuss you really because you,
you haven't been getting those hits for that lot two years.
Now this man hit you with a two years.
Uh,
um,
and you're getting used to it and you have,
you felt it and you've gotten over it.
You need to get over that hill.
Is it a mental hill?
It is a mental hill because even for me,
for me,
when I haven't fought for awhile,
you know,
I go out there until I get hit.
Once I get hit that wakes everything up was like,
Yo,
this is not supposed to go like that.
You're not supposed to hit me.
I'm supposed to hit you.
So I guess I could go in.
So the hot scene Rockman fight after it was over,
were you worried that you were going to get,
we're not going to get a rematch?
Yes,
I was very worried.
In fact,
we chased them two,
three courts around the world and the,
he didn't want to fight me and I,
you know,
if I was in this position,
I wouldn't want to fight me either because,
uh,
you know,
I'm coming back for revenge.
Plus there's a big money fight out there.
Would Tyson he so,
um,
so happened to say after the fight,
no more Louis Tyson,
no more Louis Tyson.
And he actually left um,
South Africa without visiting Mandela.
Like why you go African?
Obviously Mandela.
I did.
He just wanted to get out of there.
Yeah,
he just belt and that $7 million that he got off of Don King.
So the fight got made again because after the third courtroom the judge says,
whose signature is this?
I'll seem said it was his,
you signed it?
Yes.
Well you got to give them the rematch.
This is,
you signed it to give them a rematch so you have to give him a rematch.
So he didn't want to hear that.
So I was happy.
[inaudible] how long did it take?
Two years.
And then was all at all those brawls in the member of the ESPN studio when him
and Rockman I got into a fight at a table and everything.
Yeah.
Clinics was wearing this big Steve Harvey suit.
Did you,
let me tell you it wasn't Steve RBC to,
cause I had this,
I'm going to have the slippers shoes in the world.
I didn't come there to fight.
Right.
I came there to like,
you know,
do press slippery shoes are the worst.
If anything goes down.
You got those leather shoulds.
Oh my God.
On carpet.
You know,
just keep walking away.
That's when you got to learn Jujitsu.
Now when you were in that time period,
I don't remember.
Did you have fights in between?
Uh,
yeah.
How many fights did you have after a rock?
Oh No,
it didn't have no fights.
No fights.
No.
I just trained for Rockman just waited.
Yeah.
So it took you two years.
Two years.
Ah.
That must have been so frustrating.
It was.
It was because you never know if you're going to get the fight or not or you
know,
these guys are running from you.
They signed to fight a rematch because you know,
now they didn't want to sign it.
I remember when that right hand landed.
I remember when I was watching it at home and I threw my arms up in the air.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Yeah.
I went to sleep,
sleep.
Let's,
let's check this out man.
I mean,
for a long time coming,
you're waiting for it.
You know.
For this,
this fight Rockman couldn't cut catch me cause my speed was different.
You know,
in South Africa was a lot slower.
Now he got kind of a little frustrated because he couldn't get his boom.
Yep.
Oh Man.
No.
Over the top of the shoulder.
Cortez,
let them count though.
Oh,
that was a phenomenal player.
That was probably one of the most satisfying one punch knockouts I've ever
watched.
Yeah,
because I knew what you had gone through and I knew like everybody knew you were
one of the greatest of all time,
man,
to have you get killed like that.
First of all,
it made it endeared people to you in a way because it shows your vulnerability,
but also your character and your ability to come back,
which is not easy.
Man.
When you get stopped like that,
like psychologically,
it's got to be fucking with your head.
Let me tell you,
the first time I lost everybody was coming up and shaking my hand and said,
well,
what are you going to do now?
I'm like,
what do you mean,
what am I gonna do now?
Yeah.
Well what you to do now?
I'm going to go back and when my championship,
I said,
okay.
You know,
they didn't think it was going to be possible,
but I'm thinking Muhammad Ali gained the championship three times,
so I've only lost it once.
I can do it again.
It takes a special person to do it and I can do it.